the scottish government has previously
committed to the establishment of a
statutory public inquiry into the
handling of the pandemic and today we
have started the process of getting such
an inquiry up and running i can confirm
that it will be established by the end
of this year as promised and it will
take a person-centered human
rights-based approach
we have this morning published draft
aims and principles for the inquiry
which following following a period of
consultation which will take place
between now and the end of september
consultation with interested parties
including of course believed families
these aims and principles are intended
to become the basis for the formal terms
of reference of the inquiry a copy of
the draft and details of how you can
contribute your views if you wish to do
so can be found on the scottish
government website
i can also confirm that the lord
advocate has begun discussions with the
lord president about appointing a judge
to lead the inquiry it is fully our
intention that this will be a judge-led
inquiry
the inquiry will look at all matters
related to the handling of the pandemic
that are within our devolved competence
and this will include of course the
situation in our care homes however we
will also lays closely with the uk
government and other devolved
governments on the
likely terms of a uk-wide inquiry where
possible not least to reduce the burden
on those who will give evidence to these
inquiries it will be important to avoid
duplication and overlap however the need
for cooperation with other governments
is not in my view a reason to delay the
establishment of our own inquiry i do
believe that a full public inquiry has
an extremely important role to play both
in scrutinizing the decisions we took
and indeed continue to take in the
course of the pandemic but also of
course in identifying and learning
appropriate lessons for the future i
therefore believe that it is appropriate
to start establish that inquiry as soon
as possible now and the process we've
begun today is an important step towards
that